you look at my couch and you don't
immediately think sporty but but I need
to tell you know since big day so mark
ruffalo before you were an actor you
were a professional wrestler or going to
be a professional risk I was a wrestling
I didn't I was a high school wrestler
but I love the reason you stopped doing
it cuz you were very good at it weren't
you oh it's pretty good yeah yeah but
you stopped because well I saw the drama
department and they were like wrestling
but there was like they were just laying
in a heap of people and there was many
more girls than guys and you don't have
to cut 20 pounds every season that's
good that was soft
and listen talking of talking of sport
Amanda Holden now you were a champion
wizard gymnast in gymnastics was it the
Commonwealth Games you did no darling
come on nothing big Olympic Trials no I
did for Hampshire well
[Applause]
I'm sure in the Commonwealth Games oh
come on
Olympics her as part of the Commonwealth
tried to leave several times but now
we've got it we've got a picture of
Amanda as a child doing gymnastics is
incredibly impressive can you still do
stuff can you do the splits and things
well you can't do the splits turns and I
can do
could you do a head start I just need
you to be on a girl watch okay
I didn't agree to get them out you
needed their own manager that's all you
need okay where should I be talking with
a cushion
just just way back yes exactly like that
someone will bring a cookie okay so I
just found my makeup off is gonna kill
me for messing up my hair my company be
doing this
that was amazing
[Applause]
do the splits I'm wearing underwear I'll
just check yes that's incredible thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
so exciting ready for this exam love has
been extraordinary there's a real
there's a real excitement in the room
there's a lot of anticipation okay okay
[Music]
so that I was only joking when I said I
was gonna cuz I saw this is after what I
love about this oculus
it's got reflectors on the like you're
gonna go down the street the other
incredible thing about it is it has just
one wheel